eeuu investiga el secuestro de 17
ciudadanos norteamericanos en haití el
pasado sábado un grupo criminal retó a
los misioneros y sus familiares entre
ellos cinco niños cuando regresaban a la
capital puerto príncipe de visitar un
orfanato state department el
departamento de estado tiene como parte
de un pequeño equipo que está ahora en
el terreno que ha sido enviado a haití
para trabajar estrechamente con las
autoridades haitianas en este asunto
onstar seguiremos trabajando con el
gobierno canadiense dado que una de las
víctimas es canadiense y con nuestros
socios interinstitucionales córners en
el último año haití entró en una espiral
de inseguridad violencia crisis
económica y política este lunes las
calles de la capital habitualmente
caóticas estaban tranquilas mientras
miles de trabajadores declararon dos
días de huelga nacional liderada por los
transportistas debido a la falta de
seguridad en la isla que afecta a sus
precarias economías
en el mundo en todos los países del
mundo la seguridad es el primer bien
público significa que cuando estás en un
país que no tiene seguridad social un
grupo de bandas te obliga a desplazarte
te secuestran violan a tu hija cuando no
podemos comer también es una inseguridad
apoyo la huelga al cien por cien por el
derecho a que la vida cambie
en los últimos meses las bandas
criminales han puesto el foco en
iglesias y grupos religiosos a cambio de
extorsiones el principal sospechoso del
rapto de los misioneros 400 magos
también secuestró a 10 personas el
pasado abril